Pteronophobia is the fear of being tickled
by feathers.
It cost 7 million dollars to build the Titanic
and 200 million dollars to make a film about
it.
There is enough water in Lake Superior to
cover all of North and South America in one
foot of liquid.
when Star Wars: A New Hope hit theatres in
1977, France was still executing people using
the guillotine.
Owls don't have eyeballs.
They have eye tubes.
When hippos are upset or angry, their sweat
turns red.
Camel's milk doesn't curdle.
Nowhere in the Humpty Dumpty Nursery Rhyme
does it say that Humpty Dumpty is an egg.
Most streets in Japan don't have names.
They instead use an addressing system where
they divide areas into blocks and give the
blocks numbers.
The only two animals that can see behind themselves
without turning their head are the rabbit
and the parrot.
Elephants have a specific alarm call that
means "human".
It sounds like a deep rumble.
Horses use facial expressions and move their
ears to communicate with each other.
Every possible starting position of a standard
Rubik's Cube can be solved in 20 moves or
less.
There is only one country between North Korea
and Norway, Russia.
New York City is farther south than Rome.
Oxford University is older than the Aztec
Empire by over 300 years.